we have a deeper look this morning of a
young generations push for change
following the deadly school attack in
parkland Florida students from more than
3,000 schools walked out of class this
week to protest gun violence after last
month's massacre the survivors of the
Stoneman Douglas attack are now the
faces of a national movement for Sunday
60 minutes sharing Alphonse they spoke
with some of those at the forefront
including 18-year old Emma Gonzalez and
her mom Beth what do you think about
this idea of arming teachers it's stupid
why first of all they have Douglass ran
out of paper for like two weeks in the
school year and now all of a sudden they
have 400 million dollars to pay for
teachers to get trained to arm
themselves really really if you're a
teacher and you have a gun do you keep
it in a lockbox or do you carry it on
your person if the teacher dies and a
student who's a good student is able to
get the gun are they now held
responsible to shoot the student who's
coming to the door I'm not happy with
that where's the one with the good
handle Emma's mother Beth watched as her
daughter became one of the most
recognizable faces and one of the most
polarizing debates in the country I was
terrified it's like she built herself a
pair of wings out of balsa wood and duct
tape and jumped off a building and we're
just like running along beneath her with
a net which she doesn't want or think
that she needs what is happening to her
life
it's insane somebody said you know
please tell Emma were behind at her
which I appreciate but we should have
been in front of her I should've been in
front of her we're all adults
we should have dealt with this 20 years
ago it's a lot to ask these kids know
they're asking it of themselves but some
adults are like you go girl you changed
the law you know and like well what are
we doing well Sharon Alphonse he joins
us now at the table that emma is such a
firecracker who paints quite a picture
but I'm very touched by her mom you know
we've seen so much about the children
how are the
Aaron's dealing with what their children
are going through and how they've
responded it's funny they're kind of
hands-off with all of this but of course
you want to protect your kids
Emma's mama she said to us she said
they're like mom leave me alone because
I'm gonna change the world but I need a
ride at 6 o clock
yeah can you take me to the mall yes
yeah why do these kids think Sharon that
this time it will be different do you
think I think that's such a good
question one of the parents of one of
the victims said something I thought was
really smart and that this generation
grew up with telephones in their hands
right they're used to getting things
instantly instant answers and so they're
not gonna wait they're not gonna wait
six months they're not gonna wait a year
they want it now and they're demanding
it and they have this voice in this
platform the previous generations didn't
have what do they want well they want a
lot of things but mostly it's gun
control also to close some of the loops
and the way you buy guns online but also
at gun shows um they're very specific
they basically want to create gun
control that would have stopped another
partly because one of the things they
have some of them have said is they want
an assault weapons ban right that is I
mean there's just no appetite for that
even within the Democratic Party with
whom they are the most closely aligned
right well and they know that right they
understand that they keep saying we just
want common sense this isn't Democrat
the Republican this isn't black or white
we just want common-sense gun laws one
of the things that broke my heart that
they said is look we're the mass
shooting generation some of these kids
were born just after Columbine and they
have only known what it means to be part
of this generation they have been
practicing they have had drills they
have been in their closets
we can't relate to that they have a very
unique voice a lot of people are hoping
it will be different this time yeah
we'll see Thank You Sharon you can see
Sharon's full report Sunday night on 60
minutes it airs at 7 6 central right
here on CBS then on Monday on CBS this
morning Stoneman Douglas students emma
gonzales the one you just saw in that
piece and david hog will be here in
studio 57 to discuss their next big
project that's the march for our lives
in Washington later this month that's on
Monday right here at CBS this morning